if you ever wanted to experience battle  royale for yourself player unknowns  battlegrounds is the answer and it's  getting a lot of attention on Steam  right now I'm Tony and this is your top  selling GameSpot news update developer  blue hole announced that battlegrounds  has now sold over 2 million copies not  bad for a multiplayer only game that  just launched and early access this  March in response to that success blue  hole will be holding a charity event for  gamers outreach on its twitch channel  this Thursday May 4th the team will  match all donations up to $100,000 a  very noble move indeed player unknowns  battlegrounds is currently PC only but  blue hole is working to bring the  competitive survival game to ps4 and  Xbox one if you're subscribed to  GameSpot you'll be the first to know  when that port gets a release date and  if you want more battlegrounds action  right now you can check out our kills  montage  [Music]